the table represents the cost of buying
a small piece of land in a remote
village since the year 1990 which kind
of function best models this
relationship and I'm using this is an
example from the Khan Academy exercises
and we're really trying to pick between
whether a linear model or linear
function models this relationship or an
exponential model or exponential
function will model this relationship so
like always pause this video and see if
you can figure it out on your own
alright so now let's think about this
together so as the time goes by on this
the time variable right over here we see
that we keep incrementing it by to go
from 0 to 2 2 to 4 4 to 6 so on and so
forth it keeps going up by 2 so if this
is a linear relationship given that our
change in time is constant our change in
cost should increase by a constant
amount does it have to be this constant
but has to be a constant amount if we're
dealing with an exponential relationship
we would multiply by the same amount for
a constant change in time let's see
what's going on here let's just first
look at the difference between these
numbers to go from 30 to 36 point 9 you
would have to add 6.9 now to go from
thirty six point nine to forty four
point one what do you have to add you
have to add seven point two and now to
go from 44 point one to 51 point one you
would have to add seven now to go to 51
point one to fifty seven point nine you
are adding six point eight six point
eight and then finally going from 57.9
to sixty five point one let's see this
is almost eight seven point one this is
what seven point two we're adding plus
seven point two so you might say anyway
we're not adding the exact same amount
every time but remember this is intended
to be data that you might actually get
from real from a real-world situation
and the data that you get from a
real-world situation will never be
exactly a linear model or exactly an
exponential model but every time we add
two years it does look like we're
getting pretty close to adding $7,000 in
cost 6.9 is pretty close to seven that's
pretty close to seven that is seven is
pretty close to seven that's pretty
close to seven so this is looking like a
linear model to me you could test
whether it's an exponential model you
see well what factor am i multiplying
each time but that doesn't seem to be as
this doesn't seem to be growing
exponentially it doesn't seem like we're
multiplying by the same factor every
time it seems like we're multiplying by
a slightly lower factor as we get to
higher cost so the linear model seems to
be a pretty good thing if I see every
time I increase by two years I'm
increasing cost by six point nine or
seven point two or seven it's pretty
close to seven so it's not exactly the
cost but the model predicts it pretty
well if you were to plot these on a on a
on a on a coordinate plane and try to
connect the dots you could it would look
pretty close to a line or you could draw
a line that gets pretty close to those
dots